[संगीत]
[प्रशंसा]
खुदा
[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग दोस्तों एक बार आप
लोग सब बता दीजिए की सबको मेरी आवाज
क्लियर ए रही है
बता दीजिए एक बार चाट में सबको मेरी आवाज
सुने दे दिया
ओके थैंक यू
तो आप सभी का स्वागत युटुब चैनल पर तो
लास्ट टाइम हमने जहां से छोड़ था जहां से
हम कंटिन्यू करते हैं तो
लेडियम
क्या होता है और
कुछ रियल वर्ल्ड एग्जांपल
कुछ लोग और बीच में ए जाएंगे तो हम अपना
कंटिन्यू स्टार्ट करते हैं टॉपिक को
देखो
जिसमें टैक्स वीडियो न्यूज़ चक्र को फाइंड
आउट करने के लिए उसे किया जाता है एक
नॉर्मल इंसान के द्वारा बट पर्सपेक्टिव
इनफॉरमेशन सिक्योरिटी गूगल वर्किंग इसे
वेरी वेरी यूजफुल तो
अब एक सवाल
एक इंसान एक व्यक्ति एक परसों गूगल का उसे
करके किसी भी वेबसाइट को हैक कर सकता है
या किसी भी वेबसाइट के बड़े में सेंसेटिव
इनफॉरमेशन निकाल सकता है अगर मुझे आपको इस
सवाल का जवाब देना है तो इससे पहले मुझे
कुछ और सवाल है उनका जवाब देना होगा इस के
बाद आपको इस सवाल का जवाब अपने आप मिल
जाएगा
फर्स्ट ऑफ जो वे नीड तू अंडरस्टैंड हो
सर्च इंजन वर्क नेक्स्ट दूसरा सवाल है
वेबसाइट
अलसो वे नीड तू अंडरस्टैंड व्हाट इस
robots.t फाइल अलोंग की व्हाट इस साइट मैप
आफ्टर अंडरस्टैंडिंग जो दिस माल टॉपिक
ऑटोमेटेकली यू बिल अंडरस्टैंड डेट व्हाट
आई एम ट्रिंग तू बेसिकली
आपको देना होगा इस के बेस पर आपको गूगल डी
वर्किंग काफी अच्छे से समझ में आएगा और
देखो मेरा तरीका थोड़ा अलग होता है मैं
बिल्कुल जीरो से जाता हूं और एक
इंटरमीडिएट पे ला के छोड़ देता हूं
बेसिकली क्या है गूगल को अगर डिलीवर करने
में हार्डली 15 तू 20 मिनट लगेंगे गोल्ड
वर्किंग को मैं क्या डिलीवर कर सकता हूं
बट मैं नहीं चाहता की ओनली 20 से 15 मिनट
के अंदर किसी भी गोल्ड वर्किंग के
कॉन्सेप्ट को डिलीवर कर देना चाहिए
क्योंकि इससे एक बहुत ही बेसिक कॉन्सेप्ट
जुड़ा होता है अगर आपको उसे बेसिक
कॉन्सेप्ट का नहीं पता तो गूगल वर्किंग
करने में या कल को आपको खुद के गूगल लोग
सुनने पड़े तो आप वो बना नहीं पाओगे
तो इसलिए यह तीन कर सवाल है जैसे की जो
आपका सर्च इंजन है क्योंकि आप google.in
किसके ऊपर करते हो सर्च इंजन के ऊपर करते
हो तो अगर आपको यही नहीं पता होगा सर्च
इंजन कैसे कम करता है या सर्च इंजन होता
क्या है या वेब प्रॉब्लम जो होते हैं वो
कैसे कम करते हैं कैसे आपकी वेबसाइट
इंडेक्स होती है कैसे एक रोबोट दो टेस्टी
जो फाइल होती है उसकी क्या इंर्पोटेंस है
क्योंकि आप हैकर हो ना एथिकल हैकर तो आप
इसको फाइंड आउट करते हैं या कैसे साइट मैप
डॉट एक्सटर्नल फाइल आपको देखने को मिलती
है यह साड़ी चीज क्या है ये ट्रंप क्या है
अगर आपको इनके बड़े में नहीं पता तो आपको
गूगल वर्किंग समझना में थोड़ी सी प्रॉब्लम
हो क्योंकि गूगल डी वर्किंग जस्ट 4 कमांड
फायर करके आपको गूगल वर्किंग नहीं सिखाया
जा सकता क्योंकि उसके बिहाइंड डी से गूगल
को कैसे उसे किया जाता है कैसे वो वर्किंग
परफॉर्म की जाति है अगर उसके बेसिक
कॉन्सेप्ट आपको नहीं पता तो
शायद मुश्किल है क्योंकि मेरा तरीका यही
समझने का तो मैं ऐसे ही समझाऊंगा मुझे
लगता अगर किसी लोगों को किसी इंसान को
इंटरेस्ट नहीं है इसका बेसिक समझना में
बोला की सर हम तो गूगल वर्किंग पढ़ने आए
हैं बट आप लोग ये क्या सर्च इंजन कम करता
है क्या करोल और होता है ये सब पढ़ना वाले
हो तो आई एम सॉरी पर डेट लेकिन मेरा तरीका
यही है क्योंकि मुझे बिल्कुल आदत है बेसिक
से एक ऐसे समझने की जो सबको समझ में आए
नेक्स्ट अब बात करते हम यह देखो आपने
स्क्रीन पर देखा होगा की इस टाइप का गूगल
सर्च इंजन आपको दिखाई देता है और यहां पर
क्या है आपको एक यह स्क्रॉल बार दिखा देता
है जिसके अंदर आप कोई भी किया शब्द जब पट
करते हैं डालते हैं तो क्या होता है की
विदीन कुछ मिली सेकंड के अंदर आपको उसका
आंसर मिल जाता है तो वो आंसर आपको कैसे
मिलता है वो आंसर आपको कैसे मिलता है तो
वो आंसर कैसे मिलता है वो पता करने के लिए
आपको ये पता करना पड़ेगा सबसे पहले की यह
जो सर्च इंजन है ये होता क्या है या ये जो
सर्च इंजन है ये कम कैसे करता है
चलो फिर इसको समझते हैं तो ये सर्च इंजन
होता क्या है या सर्च इंजन से मेरा क्या
मतलब है
प्रोग्राम डेट डिजाइन तू सर्च और
इनफॉरमेशन ऑन डी वर्ल्ड वाइड वेब जिसको
बोलते हैं डब्लू डब्लू
प्रोग्राम भाई परिसर क्योंकि एक सर्च इंजन
के पास बिलियन ऑफ वेबसाइट
कल परिसर सॉफ्टवेयर प्रोग्राम और बेसिकली
इसी परिसर सॉफ्टवेयर
जो नॉर्मल यूजर्स के द्वारा उसे किया जाता
है इंटरनेट के ऊपर वह गूगल की गूगल सर्च
इंजन उसे किया जाता है
वह दूसरे जो सर्च इंजन बैक के जैसे आपका
यहां हुआ है बैंक है या अंडा है या अदर जो
सर्च इंजन बच्चे उनका उसे किया जाता है 32
20% लोगों के द्वारा अब मैं क्या बोल सकता
हूं की बेसिक ली सर्च इंजन हमारे लिए एक
इनफॉरमेशन फाइंड करने का एक मेकैनिज्म है
जिसमें हम अपनी कोई भी करी डालते हैं और
उसे रिलेटेड इनफॉरमेशन यह हमें प्रोवाइड
करता है
तो इसको समझना के लिए आपको सर्च इंजन की
वर्किंग को समझना होगा तो जो सेकंड लाइन
में मैंने कुछ लिखा है की तू सो इनफॉरमेशन
सर्च इंजन ड्यूल लोट ऑफ बैकग्राउंड वर्क
सो डेट व्हेन यू क्लिक ऑन सर्च बटन यू आर
प्रेजेंटेड विद एन सेट ऑफ पेज साइज और
क्वालिटी रिजल्ट्स डेट आंसर्स योर
क्वेश्चंस और क्यूरियस देखो इसका मतलब
क्या है की जब भी आप कोई भी के शब्द आपके
सर जो सर्च इंजन में सर्च करते हो या आपका
जो सोल वार है जो सर्च बार है उसके अंदर
कोई भी केवड़ा हो आप सर्च करते हो तो उसके
लिए उसे के शब्द का आंसर आपको प्रोवाइड
करने के लिए सर्च इंजन पहले से ही बहुत सर
बैकग्राउंड करके बैठा हुआ होता है तो उसे
बैकग्राउंड क को मैंने तीन स्टडीज में
डिवाइड किया मैंने नहीं किया ये ऑलरेडी सो
सर्च इंजन ऑप्शन का कॉन्सेप्ट
बोलते हैं और थर्ड को हम रैंकिंग बोलते
हैं
ज्यादा पढ़ने वाले नहीं है
तो कॉलिंग
बोल सकते हैं
प्रोग्राम था अरे रिस्पांसिबल पर फाइंडिंग
इनफॉरमेशन था इस पब्लिकली अवेलेबल ऑन डी
इंटरनेट
प्रोग्राम है जो क्या करता है की जो
इंटरनेट पर जो भी आपकी इनफॉरमेशन अवेलेबल
है उसको फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करता है
तो डीज प्रोग्राम स्कैन डी वेब और क्रिएट
ए लिस्ट ऑफ जो वेबसाइट
और स्कैन डी वॉल एचटीएमएल कोड और दें
ट्राई तू अंडरस्टैंड
किया जाता है
आपके पूरे वेब को स्कैन करता है और वहां
से क्या है तो
वेबसाइट के हर एक पेज को स्कैन करता है
पूरे एचटीएमएल कोड को क्या करता है वह
स्कैन करता है और वहां से समझना की कोशिश
करता है की वेब पेज का स्ट्रक्चर क्या है
किस टाइप्स का उसके अंदर कंटेंट है कंटेंट
का क्या मीनिंग है कब वह क्रिएट किया गया
था कब वो अपडेट किया था इस टाइप की
इनफॉरमेशन वो समझना की कोशिश करता है देखो
जब भी हम कोई भी वेबसाइट क्रिएट करते हैं
या चाहे हम कुछ भी उसमें अपडेशन क करते
हैं चाहे हम कोई भी एक ब्लॉक बी क्यों ना
पोस्ट करते हो ऐसे में गूगल का जो क्राउलर
है जिसको हम स्पाइडर-मैन भी बोलते हैं उसे
साइड डाटा को क्या करता है करोड़ करता है
क्या कर दिया वो सर्च इंजन को दे दिया
कॉलिंग करने के बाद उसमें सर्च इंजन को दे
दिया और सर्च इंजन ने क्या किया उसको अपने
लोकल सर्वर में स्टोर कर लिया साड़ी डाटा
को
जब गूगल सर्च इंजन के पास इतने सारे
इनफॉरमेशन
आई है
तो उसका वो क्या करेगा
सिंपली इतनी साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन है उसके पास
बिलियन ऑफ वेबसाइट की यात्री वेबसाइट की
अगर उसको अपना बेस्ट रिजल्ट देना है तो
उसको क्या करना पड़ेगा उसके लिए उसको क्या
करना पड़ेगा उसकी इंडेक्सिंग करनी होगी
इंडेक्सिंग का मतलब क्या है
जैसे लाइब्रेरी में होता है
तो अब अगला सवाल और सर इंडेक्सिंग क्यों
अगर किसी भी वेबसाइट को गूगल के सर्च
इंडेक्स में आना है तो उसको क्या करना
होगा क्राउलिंग करवाने ही होगी अदर वाइस
वो आपकी गूगल के सर्च इंजन में क्या हो गई
बिजीबल नहीं होगी अगर उसकी क्राउलिंग नहीं
हुई तो उसे वेबसाइट की इंडेक्सिंग नहीं
होगी अगर वो वेबसाइट की इंडेक्सिंग नहीं
होगी तो वो आपकी सर्च रिजल्ट में कभी भी
दिखाई नहीं देगी दिखाई नहीं दी होगी तो
जनरली जो सर्च इंजन उसे साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन
को स्टोर नहीं करते वो हर एक वेबसाइट के
कुछ एलिमेंट को स्टोर देते हैं जैसे की
टाइटल हो गया वेबसाइट का डिस्क्रिप्शन हो
गया पेज के या टाइप्स ऑफ कंटेंट हो गया या
कुछ एसोसिएटेड कीवर्ड्स हो गए या नंबर ऑफ
इनकमिंग आउटगोइंग लिंक
फॉर्मेशन हो क्या कर सकते हैं क्या करते
हैं अब क्या होता है की मैं एक एग्जांपल
लेट हूं आप लोगों के सामने इधर एक
एग्जांपल है की मैंने एक एग्जांपल लिया की
एक लाइब्रेरी है और वहां पर उसके अंदर तीन
एम्पलाई हैं
उसके अंदर क्या है
और
क्या करते हैं की जब आप लाइब्रेरी में आप
उसके इंचार्ज हो सुपरवाइजर है तो आपने
क्या एक एंपलॉयर को बोला ठीक है वन आगे
उसकी साड़ी बुक्स निकालो और लाइब्रेरी के
जो सेंट्रलाइज्ड है तो
जिसने जो एम्पलाई वन था उसने क्या किया वो
साड़ी बुक्स वन से निकाल के आपके जो
लाइब्रेरी थी उसके अंदर किसी एक टेबल के
ऊपर वो सारे के सारे रख दी तो
वन से लेकर तक लेकर आने तक जो एम्पलाई था
उसको हम बोल सकते हैं वो एक वेब क्राउलर
है या उसको हम बोल सकते हैं
आपने क्या बोला है जो सुपरवाइजर थे इवेंट
में तू को क्या बोला की आप एक कम कीजिए
यहां पर पहले से पार्टीशन बनाए हुए हैं
इंडेक्स बनाए हुए हैं तो आपको क्या करना
है अगर हिंदी हिंदी लिटरेचर तो आपको हिंदी
हिंदी वाली में रखना इंग्लिश लिटरेचर
इंग्लिश वाले में अभी हिस्ट्री की
हिस्ट्री वाले में साइंस की साइंस वाले
में मठ की मठ वाले में नवल नवल वाले ने इस
टाइप से वहां पर इंडेक्सिंग की
अरेंज करना है तो एम्पलाई तू को हम क्या
बोल सकते हैं इंडक्शन उसने क्या का दिया
उसको इंडेक्सिंग कर दी बहुत आई है
क्या बोला की आपका कम है भैया आपको क्या
है रिसेप्शन पे बैठना है कोई भी आपसे कोई
रिक्वेस्ट करता है कोई भी आपके पास आता है
आपको क्या करना है आपको रिक्वेस्ट करनी है
उसको क्या है उसे बुक्स की उसे बुक्स को
का देना है आपको दे देना है उसको अलग कर
देना है अब जो वो थर्ड है जिसको हम बोल
सकते हैं रैंकिंग भी बोल सकते हैं अब वो
क्या है सबसे पहले जब भी वो किसी बुक की
रिक्वेस्ट की जाएगी वो सिंपली जाएगा और
फटाफट बुक्स को निकाल के लिए आएगा अब वो
फटाफट कैसे निकाल के लगो लेक ए सकता है
एक-एक कार्ड मिलेगा जब उसने इंडेक्स
रैंकिंग अच्छे से की होगी
पता है की सबसे ज्यादा कौन सी मांगी जाति
है तो इसलिए क्या है वो टॉप में मिलेगी
उसमें तो उठा के ले आएगा अगर कोई ऐसी
बुक्स होगी जो
कभी हरि कोई रिक्वेस्ट करता है तो उसको
टाइम लगेगा तो उसको लेकर आने दो इसी
प्रकार से आपका वेबपेज भी ऐसे कम करता है
तो ये था मेरा एक एग्जांपल छोटा सा
लाइब्रेरी का एग्जांपल इसके थ्रू आप लोगों
को समझ में ए गया होगा की
वेबक्रोलिंग इंडेक्सिंग और रैंकिंग कैसे
कम करती है चलो मैं एक और करके दिखता हूं
की हो कलर डी वेबसाइट
है मी website.com मैंने मी website.com
को मैंने क्या कर दिया फोर्स कर दिया
जब मैंने मेरी वेबसाइट को मैंने क्या किया
होस्ट किया तो वेबक्रॉलर आया वेबक्रॉलर ने
क्या किया मेरी वेबसाइट को करोल किया करो
करके उसने सारे वेब कंटेंट्स को रीड किया
और वहां से उसमें कौन सी इनफॉरमेशन रीड की
उसका टाइटल है डिस्क्रिप्शन है किस टाइप
का वो कंटेंट है कैश स्ट्रक्चर है इस पेज
की क्या मीनिंगफुल कंटेंट है कभी अब ये
साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन क्योंकि ये फर्स्ट टाइम
आई है तीन इनफॉरमेशन उसने क्या कर दी
क्रॉस ने करोल किया अब स्क्रॉल करने के
बाद क्या है इसने क्या है डिक्शनरी और
कंटेंट सर्च कीवर्ड्स इमेज डिकोडेड में
क्रोम के द्वारा वो कुछ डाटा कलेक्ट कर
लिया गया सर का सर डाटा नहीं है जो मैंने
बताया था टाइटल हो गया डिस्क्रिप्शन हो
गया है उसका कंटेंट होगा उसकी शब्द हो गया
या इमेज होगी उससे रिलेटेड तो उसने क्या
उसको क्रॉस करके फिर उसने एक लिस्ट बनाई
की शब्द की ओके ये एप्पल बनाना स इसके
अंदर से वेबसाइट के अंदर से क्या है ये
कीवर्ड्स उसने क्या किया फाइंड आउट किया
और उसने अपने साथ डाटा में लेकर गया और
उसने क्या का दिया सर्च इंजन को दे दिया
सर्च इंजन ने क्या किया वो अपने जो लोकल
स्टोर वो क्या था आपका लोकल सर्वर था उसने
लोकल सर्वे में जाके इसको स्टोर कर लिया
नेक्स्ट जब भी ये यूजर सबमिट है ओके मैं
इसको समझता हूं जब भी आपने क्या किया स जो
एक स की ये शब्द था उसको आपने अपने सर्च
इंजन को दिया आपने क्या किया
1 मिनट
में क्या किया
जैसे आपने वेबसाइट को क्या किया था की
लोकल सर्वर पर स्टोर किया था उसके जो
कीवर्ड्स को तो वहां पर क्या इंडेक्सिंग
कर दी इंडेक्स के द्वारा और वहां पर क्या
एक ऑर्गेनाइजर भी मत रख दिया गया तो उसने
क्या किया लोकल सर्वर के पास गया आपका
सर्च इंजन वहां से पता किया ओके स किसको
के शब्द है तो उसके पता चला यहां पे भाई
मिस्टेक क्या है एनोडर website.com लिख
दिया गया है इस इमेज को जो मैंने उठाया था
कहानी से तो आई एम सॉरी website.com तो
गया मी website.com पे उसके बाद उसने देखा
उसको फेस करके आपकी वेबसाइट का वो वेब पे
था उसने आपके स्क्रीन पे शो कर दिया
नेक्स्ट अब बात आई है फिर से क्या करोगे
क्या कम करते रहते हैं क्रॉस तो रोल करते
रहते हैं तो आपने क्या किया देखिए आपकी मी
website.com थी क्योंकि अभी तक क्या है
सर्च इंजन के पास एक ही डोमेन है मी
website.com क्योंकि फर्स्ट टाइम में ऐसा
सीनरी है बिल्कुल भी फर्स्ट टाइम बिल्कुल
नया था तो मी वेबसाइट आपने उसमें क्या कर
दिया एक को किसी दूसरी वेबसाइट का लिंक एड
कर दिया ओके
रहना चेक करते लड़की वेबसाइट में कुछ
अपडेट हुआ कुछ नहीं हुआ तो गया मी
website.com फिर से वेबसाइट कंटेंट देखो
ओके कीवर्ड्स एप्पल बनाना से है कुछ उसमें
चेंज नहीं है नेक्स्ट शो एक यूआरएल मिला
और अंदर website.com तो उसमें यूआरएल पर
जाता है और वहां उसके भी वेब कंटेंट्स को
क्या करता है रोल करता है उसे पता करना है
की इसमें कौन-कौन से कंटेंट्स हैं कौन-कौन
से दूसरे पेज हर पेज को उसे क्या करता है
स्क्रॉल करता है और करोड़ करने के बाद
स्पाइडर करता है उसके बाद क्या है उसको
क्या कीवर्ड्स निकले उसने टोमेटो
स्ट्रॉबेरी और पाइनएप्पल नाम की तीन ही के
शब्द निकाल पाया उसने दोनों को डाटा
क्या-क्या कंबाइन किया फिर से क्या कर
दिया आपने सर्च इंजन को उसने वापस से दे
दिया की अभी मेरे को ये डाटा मिला है आप
अपने लोकल सर्विस में इंस्टॉल कर लीजिए अब
इसमें स्टोर कर लिया फिर से तो इस तरीके
से प्रोसेस चलती रहती है की आप एक वेबसाइट
के अंदर कितने भी लिंक
पट इन करोगे
एक कीवर्ड लिस्ट बनाकर डाटा कलेक्ट करके
सर्वर को दे देता है अब आप बोलोगे की एक
ही कलर कम करता है नहीं ऐसा नहीं होता 1
करोड़ लोग अपने आप को मल्टीप्लाई कर सकता
है वो क्या करता है एक वेबसाइट को जैसे
मैं website.com है वो क्या है इसको कल कर
रहा था उसके बाद जैसे दूसरा वहां से
जेनरेट किया और अमेजॉन website.com दूसरा
ये प्रॉब्लम छोड़ दिया तो इस तरीके से
रोलिंग कम करती है अब नेक्स्ट टाइम ये है
तो छोटू रिचर्ड दिस सर्च इंजन नो हज नॉलेज
ऑफ तू डम्स डेट हैव मी website.com और डी
वेबसाइट अब इसके पास क्या है इसकी नॉलेज
में दो दो मिंस भाई website.com और उसके
बाद इंडेक्सिंग कैसे हो राखी है डोमेन नाम
कौन सा है मी वेबसाइट डॉ इसका क्या शब्द
एप्पल भी है बनाना है पीएसईबी है और अंदर
website.com टमेटोज़ अनदर website.com
strawberry.com पाइनएप्पल इस तरीके से
क्या करता है ये अपना कम करता है
इंडेक्सिंग होती रहती है वेबसाइट की
ओके तो अब बात करते हैं
टोमेटो स्ट्रॉबेरी और एप्पल इसके बाद है
अब हुआ क्या की अंदर website.com
website.com website.com के अदर लिंक और
उनके भी क्या है की कीवर्ड्स कौन से मिले
टोमेटो स्ट्रॉबेरी शर्म की और से तो इस
प्रकार से क्या है की आपकी जितने भी जो
बिलियन ट्रेलर्स ऑफ वेबसाइट स्टोर है वो
इसी प्रकार से स्टार्टिंग से कम किया था
वेब के द्वारा ऐसे कम करते हैं तो आई हो
मुझे एक चीज बता दीजिए की आप सबको यहां पर
जो वेब प्रॉब्लम था सबको समझ में आया या
नहीं आया प्लीज चाट में यस नो बता दीजिए
आई एम सॉरी चलो फिर नेक्स्ट आगे बढ़ते हैं
हम डिस्कस करते हैं आपने बहुत बार सुनाओगी
करने बैठने तो सबसे पहले आप किसी भी
वेबसाइट के अंदर क्या ट्राई करते हो की
आपको क्या मिलेगी रोबोट 2 देखने को मिले
हैकर फर्स्ट इनफॉरमेशन
व्हाट इसे डी क ऑफ दिस फाइल और वही इसे सो
इंपॉर्टेंट
भी क्यों है ये सारे सवालों के जवाब मैं
अभी आपको देने वाला हूं तो रोबोट डॉट
क्योंकि हर कोई हैकर से आपको देखने को
मिलेगा की अगर आपको
अगर यह क्या है
की कोई भी हैक करिए
थोड़ा सा मजा ए जाता है अगर उसमें कोई
इनफॉरमेशन
की अभी तक मैंने आपको क्या बताया की किसी
भी वेबसाइट को किसी भी सर्च इंजन के
रिजल्ट में आना है तो उसको क्या एक
प्रोसेस का प्रोसेस के थ्रू गुजरा पड़ता
है और हर एक सर्च इंजन के अपने कुछ
प्रोग्राम्स होते हैं जिन्हें हम आ जिनको
कॉल बोलते हैं
उसको अगर इंटरनेट पर एक वेबसाइट को सॉरी
इंटरनेट पर हर एक वेबसाइट को कल किया जाता
है तो बेसिकली क्या बोल सकते हैं वह
प्रॉब्लम भी बोल सकते हैं तो अब ये एक जोक
में भी किसी एक प्रिंसिपल पे कम करते हैं
जब भी यह किसी भी वेबसाइट को करोड़ करते
हैं तो वह सबसे पहले यह चेक करते हैं की
उसे वेबसाइट के डोमेन में या उसे सर्वर पर
रोड डायरेक्टरी ने एक फाइल है या नहीं है
उसे फाइल का नाम है
robot.dxt इस फाइल का मेजर कम ये होता है
की एक सर्वर पर या एक वेब एप्लीकेशन पर
कौन सा कंटेंट क्रॉल होना चाहिए और कौन सा
कंटेंट नहीं होना चाहिए तो इस फाइल में
होता क्या है इस फाइल का भी अपना एक अपना
फॉर्मेट होता है जिसमें आपको देखने को मिल
रहा हो यहां पे देखो यूजर एजेंट देखने को
मिल रहा है
जीजा जी क्या है ये जो यूजरनेंट है यहां
पर क्या है क्राउलर का नाम राहत है कई जगह
स्टार मिला है इसका मतलब की सभी के सभी को
क्रॉस कर सकते हैं या अगर पर्टिकुलर किसी
नाम दिया है जब अमेजॉन बोट है या बिग बोट
है तो अगर किसी पार्टिकल का नाम दिया गया
है इसका मतलब क्या है की वही इस जो
वेबसाइट को क्रॉस कर सकता है
की भैया अगर आप मेरी वेबसाइट का रोल भी कर
रहे हो तो आपको क्या करना है
कंटेंट मेंशन किया है आपको उसको कल नहीं
करना है जो अलाउ है इस को ओनली स्क्रॉल
करना है एडरवाइज अगर आप अलाउ नहीं करते तो
ओनली दे सलव वाली चीज को छोड़ के बाकी सब
को क्या-क्या रोल करेगा स्क्रॉल मिलेगा
मतलब क्या होता है की आप जब भी करोड़ कर
रहे हो तो थोड़ा सा डिले कीजिए मतलब एक
रोलिंग से दूसरी क्राउलिंग के बीच में
थोड़ा कुछ सेकंड का लिए कीजिए भैया हो
सकता है की कुछ प्रॉब्लम हो या आप क्योंकि
आपकी वेबसाइट में थोड़ी सी प्रॉब्लम चल
रही है आपकी वीडियो सर्च स्लो चल रही हो
इसलिए तो ये एक फॉर्मेट होता है क्रॉलर का
और जो ये जो रोबोट जो टक्स है फाइल्स होती
है ये आपकी रूट डायरेक्टरी के अंदर देखने
को मिलती है तो ये आपको समझ में ए गया
होगा की ये रोबोट डॉट एचडी फाइल का कैसा
फॉर्मेट होता है तो यह फाइल को यह बताती
है की इस वेबसाइट का कौन सा कंटेंट
एक्सेसिबल होना चाहिए और कौन सा नहीं होना
चाहिए अब इसका मतलब ये नहीं है की आप
रोबोट दो टक्स फाइल को कोई भी प्राइवेट
इनफॉरमेशन हायड करने के लिए उसे करोगे
बोला ठीक है कम कर देता हूं प्राइवेट करके
रख देता हूं ऐसा नहीं है नहीं बस ये क्या
है की बताने के लिए है लेकिन यही मिस्टेक
करते हैं डेवलपर की वो बाय मिस्टेक कुछ
ऐसी इनफॉरमेशन होती जो प्राइवेट इनफॉरमेशन
है वो डिश अलाव में मेंशन कर देते हैं
जिसकी वजह से कोई भी हैक कर कोई भी एथिकल
हैकर क्या बोलना है की ये हर एक हैक करके
क्या है ये
की फेवरेट फाइल रोबोट डॉट फाइल अगर उसके
अंदर आपको कुछ देखने को मिलता है तो
क्योंकि बाय मिस्टर डेवलपर कुछ ऐसी
इनफॉरमेशन यहां पर छोड़ कर चले जाते हैं
जो हिडन होती है जिसको क्या है ब्रेड
फोर्स करके कुछ भी अदर टेक्निक्स का उसे
करके एनिमेशन स्कैनिंग करके उसे इनफॉरमेशन
क्या किया जा सकता है एक्सेस किया जा सकता
है या कोई भी सेंसेटिव इनफॉरमेशन यहां पर
लिखे हो सकते कोई एडमिन पेज छुपा रखा है
या कुछ भी छुपा रखा है तो वो साड़ी चीज
यहां पर एक्चुअल में नहीं हनी चाहिए तो
इसी चीज का क्या है की रोबोट और स्ट का
लोग फायदा उठाते हैं तो ये है आपकी वो
रोबोट और टेस्ट फाइल जो सबकी फेवरेट है
डेवलपर को क्यों प्रेफर करते हैं और
आर्टिकल हैकर भी इसको फाइंड आउट करना
क्यों प्रिपेयर करते हैं और हर एक वेबसाइट
के पास ये होती है देखने को सबको मिलती है
कुछ लोग इसको हाइट भी कर देते हैं क्योंकि
ये ऐसी फाइल है
की एक्टर रूट डायरेक्टरी में होती है और
दूसरा क्या है की ऐसा नहीं की ओनली इसको
क्या कर सकता है एक्सेस कर सकता है इसको
कोई भी एक्सेस कर सकता है जैसा की आप
स्क्रीन में देख का रहे हैं
अब
बात करते हैं की एक साइड में सता है साइट
मैप होता क्या है की साइड में हो सकता है
की आपकी वेबसाइट ज्यादा उलझी हुई है
और आपकी वेबसाइट क्या है की इंडेक्स में
और आपकी वेबसाइट क्या है गूगल के सर्च
इंजन पे भी नहीं ए का रही है तो क्या है
की उसके लिए साइट मैप बनाकर रखा जाता है
साइड में बना के रखा है पर एग्जांपल जैसे
मेरी एक वेबसाइट है example.com एक व्यू
example.com अबाउट स्काइप पेज है
कॉन्टैक्ट्स है कैटिगरी है एक प्रोडक्ट वन
है सब कैटिगरी का पार्ट है और प्रोडक्ट तू
भी क्या है सब कैटिगरी के अंदर आता है अब
आपको इसको देख के ग रहा है की ये क्या है
ये आपको लगता है की हर एक अलग अलग पेज है
लेकिन ये सब कैटिगरी के पार्ट है अब क्या
है की कॉलर आया
उसके बाद क्या है कॉन्टैक्ट्स पे चला गया
उसके बाद वो किसमे चला गया कैटिगरी वन
कैटिगरी चला गया उसके बाद क्या है फिर
प्रोडक्ट वन पता है प्रोडक्ट वन से फिर से
क्या किया वो कैटिगरी वन पर गया है ऐसे
फिर
मतलब ये क्या है छोटा सा एक एग्जांपल है 5
पेज के साथ अगर क्या पेज बहुत ज्यादा बड़ी
वेबसाइट है कंफ्यूज हो गया ना क्राउन करने
में काफी टाइम ग रहा है उसको और हो सकता
है की कुछ हो स्किप भी कर जाए कुछ वो
स्किप भी कट जाए इसी वजह से हम क्या करते
हैं साइट मैप का उसे करते हैं साइट मैप
क्या होता है की इस प्रकार से देखो आपको
देखने को मिल रहा है की आपको सबसे ऊपर एक
example.com मिलेगा उसके बाद क्या है
अबाउट फिर कॉन्टैक्ट्स अबाउट स के नीचे
हमने सब कैटिगरी सबका प्रोडक्ट
ऐसे ठीक मैप बना के दे दिया तो क्राउलर
आएगा ओके
example.com अबाउट उसमें गया यार उसके बाद
कॉन्टैक्ट्स में गया उसके बाद कस्टम
कैटिगरी में गया प्रोडक्ट इतना आसानी से
उसका भी कम आसन और हमारा भी कम आसन दूसरा
साइड में क्या दो टाइप्स के होते हैं एक
एचटीएमएल सेट मैप होता है एक एसएमएल सेट
मैप होता है इस्टैबलिश्ड टाइम आपके यूजर्स
के लिए उसे किया जाता है और एक्सटर्नल सेट
मैप क्या होता है क्राउलर के उसे किया
जाता है जो एचटीएमएल सेट मैप है जो हम
देखते हैं किसी वेबसाइट के अंदर आपको बहुत
ही आसानी से पता था की इसका कांटेक्ट पेज
ये है यहां पर कांटेक्ट करना तो ये फॉर्म
यहां पे मिलेगा लॉगिन हमें यहां पर करना
है उसके बाद इसका होम पेज ये है उसके बाद
ऐसे छोटे-छोटे आपको क्या है किसी भी
वेबसाइट पर
देखने मिलता है ताकि आपका जो यूजर्स है वो
स्मूथली वेबसाइट को क्या करता है नेविगेट
कर पे इस प्रकार
के ताकि वो जो एग्जैक्ट स्ट्रक्चर
अब बात करते हैं हमारा
व्हाट इसे गूगल डी अब गूगलड होता क्या है
देखो
क्योंकि देखो मैंने यह जितने भी चीज बताई
आपको की आप क्राउलर है या वेब क्राउलर्स
है यह आपको मैंने साइड में बताया रोबोट और
टक्स ये साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन का देगा पार्ट है
अब एक चीज बताइए मेरे को की अगर आपको
क्रुएल के बड़े में पता नहीं है आपके
वेबसाइट इंडेक्स कैसे होती है आप ऐसे एक
वेबसाइट के बड़े में सर्च करने की कोशिश
कर रहे हो की अभी डायरेक्ट गूगल से
ब्लाइंड्ली ऐसी वेबसाइट के बड़े में सर्च
करने कुछ कर रहे हो की वो सिर्फ इंडेक्स
ही नहीं है क्योंकि वो गूगल के पास उसकी
इनफॉरमेशन ही नहीं है और आप ब्लाइंड्ली
लगे हुए हैं की उसको
बोलना की गूगल खराब है गूगल वर्किंग कहां
है तो नहीं है क्योंकि आपको पता ही नहीं
ना क्योंकि आप में अगर एक बार नॉर्मल सर्च
करके देखोगे उसे वेबसाइट को तब वो तब भी
वो नहीं ए रही तो अब गूगल दोस्त को तो
वैसे नहीं मिलेगी
क्योंकि वह वेबसाइट इंडेक्स नहीं हुई अगर
आपको बिहाइंड डी सीन इस लॉजिक का पता ही
नहीं तो कैसे नोट पॉसिबल क्योंकि देखो
किसी भी कॉन्सेप्ट का एक बेसिक कॉन्सेप्ट
होता है तो मेरा मोटो यही राहत है की किसी
भी कॉन्सेप्ट को समझने से पहले उसका बेसिक
कॉन्सेप्ट समझा दो तो एवं किसी भी चीज को
आप कम करोगे ना तो आपको थोड़ा सा और
ज्यादा मजा आएगा जी तरीके से मुझे आपको
पढ़ना में मजा ए रहा है ना इस तरीके से
मुझे सीखने में मजा आया मजा आया था और
आपको भी सीखने में मजा आना चाहिए देखो अब
बात करते हैं की गूगल दो होता क्या है
देखो ये दो बच्चे बना हुआ है गूगल प्लस
में डोर अब गूगल का आपको पता है की गूगल
क्या है पहले मैं बता चुका हूं की सर्च
इंजन क्या है वो मैं बता देता हूं और सर्च
इंजन कैसे कम करता है ये भी मैं आपको बता
चुका हूं अब बात करते हैं डोर डोर बेसिकली
क्या है करी है डेट यू सर जो आप सर्च करते
हो या एक करी ऑपरेटर है डॉट बेसिकली उसको
बोलते हैं हम अब बात करते google.in
google.in ब्लैक बॉक्स पेन टेस्टिंग के
अंदर आता है ब्लैक बॉक्स टाइप पेन
टेस्टिंग क्या होती है की आपको
कुछ भी नहीं पता किसी चीज के बड़े में
जस्ट आपको एक यूआरएल दे दिया गया या कोई
आपको एक आईपी एड्रेस दे दिया गया तो आपको
सिंपली क्या करना है उसमें आगे मैच आगे
पॉसिबल इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करनी है उसके
बाद उसमें बल्लमपति को ढूंढना है अगर
उसमें वल्लबिलटी है तो उसको रिपोर्ट करना
है ये होती है ब्लैक बुक पेन टेस्टिंग
दूसरी होती है एक व्हाइट बोर्ड बॉक्स पेन
टेस्टिंग व्हाइट बॉक्स मेट टेस्टिंग में
क्या होती है वो कंपनी के अंदर होती है
वहां पर आपको क्या होता है की आपको सोर्स
कोड दे दिया जाता है तो आपको क्या करना है
की हम आपको आपके पास बहुत साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन
होती है उसे वेबसाइट से रिलेटेड उसका
सोर्स होता है तो उसके बाद उसके अंदर आपको
पेन टेस्टिंग करनी होती है और उसके बाद
उसके अंदर बैग निकालना होते हैं उसको
टेस्ट करने का रिपोर्ट करना होता है तो दो
टाइप्स की टेस्टिंग की जाति है ब्लैक
बॉक्स टेस्टिंग और व्हाइट बॉक्स टेस्टिंग
तो गूगल वर्किंग क्या है ब्लैक बॉक्स
टेस्टिंग के लिए उसे की जाति है ओके तो अब
बात करते हैं
अब
अब जो हमने क्या बताया था की जो डार्क है
वह क्या है करी है तो अब थोड़ा सा लेफ्ट
सर्च करिए देखो अगर हम जो सर्च करें उसको
अगर तूने अप करेंगे ना उसके साथ थोड़ा
छेड़छाड़ करेंगे उसको समझना की कोशिश
करेंगे तो हम अपने जल अच्छे और बेहतर
तरीके से लेकर ए सकते हैं अच्छे तरीके और
बेहतर तरीके से का सकते हैं देखो आफ्टर
ट्यूनिंग अप अवर सर्च थ्योरी वे बिल फाइंड
सम मोर इनफॉरमेशन एक वेल इन डी वेदर देखो
क्या अगर आप अपनी जो सर्च कारी को अच्छे
से तूने कर पाते हैं समझ पाते हैं तो मतलब
हो सकता है की जो डेवलपर के द्वारा कुछ
ऐसी सेंसेटिव इनफॉरमेशन जो उन्होंने सोचा
भी नहीं होगी वो आप तक पहुंच जाए आप उसे
तक पहुंच जैन या आप उसको सर्च कर पे यही
पूरा कॉन्सेप्ट होता है गूगल दोस्त का अब
कुछ ऑपरेटर होते हैं सब ऑपरेटर जो बेसिकली
आप जब भी क्या करते हो
तो अब क्या है की आपने देखा होगा की लिस्ट
ऑफ सर्च ऑपरेटर
जो इंटेक्स
यह सारे चीज आपको जो इंटेक्स शायद यहां पर
गलत हो गया होगा जो टेक्स्ट होगा|
ऑपरेटर आपको देखने को बेसिकली सुनने को
अभी देखने को मिलते हैं साइट इन और
इंडेक्स फाइल टाइप तो हर एक का क्या मतलब
है कैसे इनको उसे करना है क्योंकि ये सर्च
ऑपरेटर है क्योंकि जब इंडेक्सिंग की जाति
है वहां इसी टाइप से थोड़ी बहुत लेट इन
इंडेक्सिंग की जाति है ताकि ये आसानी से
बहुत ही बेहतरीन तरीके से आपके लिए रिजल्ट
आपकी स्क्रीन पे शो कर पे चलो फिर
ली ट्वीट प्रैक्टिकल इसको हम प्रैक्टिकल
करते हैं तो एक बार मुझे कंफर्म कर दीजिए
आप सबको अभी तक मैंने जितना भी कॉन्सेप्ट
बताया है की गूगल टॉकिंग होते क्या है जो
उसका बेसिक है तो सबको समझ में आया
देखो यहां पर क्या है की मैं सिर्फ एक ऐसे
इंसान को लेकिन चल रहा है की जो एक्सपर्ट
है एक्सपर्ट है वो एक्सपर्ट है बट क्या है
की मैं उन लोगों को भी साथ में लेकर चल
रहा हूं जिनको सच में इस नॉलेज की जरूर थी
तो प्लीज मुझे बता दिया हम प्रैक्टिकल जा
रहे हैं प्रैक्टिकल करने वाले
सभी बता दीजिए एक बार जितने भी लोग हैं
चलो करते हैं फिर प्रैक्टिकल करते हैं
google.com
मैंने क्या सर्च किया की मैंने क्या करना
बेस्ट जैसे मैंने बेस्ट लैपटॉप्स करता हूं
मैं ल ए पी टी ओ पीसीएल लैपटॉप तो सर
कॉन्सेप्ट ऐसे कम करता है की इसने फाटक से
आपका जो रिजल्ट है आपकी स्क्रीन पे शो कर
दिया और आपको देखने को मिलते हैं बेस्ट
लैपटॉप्स इसके ध्यान में देना ध्यान रखना
की देखो मैं एक साथ के साथ एक ओपन कर लेट
हूं 1 मिनट रखना है मुझे एक मिनट एक
न्यू x.com
अब यह देखना एक चीज ध्यान से बेस्ट
देखना कंट्रोल
सीखना हूं ये कंट्रोल भी अभी इसी वाले में
देखना की आपको जहां एक सर्च एक पैरामीटर
बना होगा सर्च करी का एक पैरामीटर होगा जब
भी हम क्या करते हो ये पैरामीटर देखो
बेस्ट एक ये पैरामीटर बन गया के मैं इस
लैपटॉप सो ये जो भी है व्हाइट से का मतलब
मुझे और इसके बाद एक और पैरामीटर पढ़ा
होगा इसमें ये रहा और करके ये बाकी इसके
अलावा मुझे कोई मतलब नहीं है देखो ए इसको
मैं तो इस टाइप से क्या है की आपकी करी भी
बंटी है उसको डिलीट कर देता हूं अभी इसको
मैं कर देता हूं डिलीट यहां तक अब इसका भी
कुछ ना कुछ मतलब होगा भाई समझा नहीं है ना
बट आपको देख लिया यहां पर एक इस टाइप से
देखो एक प्रकार से बनी है देखो के इक्वल
तू बेस्ट प्लस लैपटॉप के इक्वल तू प्लस का
मतलब स्पेस है ये क्योंकि इसको क्या कहते
हैं ये वाला इनकॉर्डिंग किया गया है तो
देखो इसके अंदर करी के अंदर ही आपका क्या
है पैरामीटर बन रहा है जो आपने सर्च किया
है उसका पैरामीटर बन रहा है तो आपको सही
स्क्रीन पर सबसे पहले दिखाई दे रहा है
देखो
तो इसी तरीके से क्या
करते हैं
ये क्या है आपका एक नॉर्मल सेल्स है जो एक
नॉर्मल इंसान है एक नॉर्मल यूजर्स
पर्सपेक्टिव हम क्या करते हैं इसको यूजुअल
करते हैं तो अब बात करते हैं हम कैसे इन
यूआरएल उसको जो गूगल डॉल्फिन का उसे करते
हैं पर एग्जांपल मुझे ये क्या करना है की
मुझे एक ऐसी वेबसाइट को सर्च करना है की
पर एग्जांपल मेरा क्या है लिखना हूं साइट
साइट क्योंकि यूआरएल है साइड एक ऑपरेटर है
उसके बाद मैं साइड उसके बाद मैंने लिखा
डॉलर सॉरी
star.com मैं क्या चाहता हूं की ये उन
साड़ी वेबसाइट को लिस्ट करें जिसके लास्ट
mein.com हो और इन यूआरएल
और इसमें मैं क्या दे रहा हूं पर एग्जांपल
है जी पर्टिकुलर साइट को मैं क्या कहना
चाहता हूं सर्च करना चाहता हूं पर्टिकुलर
साइट में पार्टिकल साइट तो मैंने क्या
किया की लास्ट mein.com होना चाहिए और
स्टार्टिंग में कुछ भी हो और इन यूआरएल का
मतलब क्या होता है की यूआरएल में इंडिया
आना चाहिए जिसमें इंडिया देख रहे हो
मिलेगा और इसको क्या करता हूं सर्च कर लेट
हूं तो ये साड़ी लेफ्ट साइड शक रहे जिनके
ये आलमी इंडिया देखो वे india.com ये रहा
देखो इधर भी साइड इंडिया ये आपको देखने को
मिल रहा है ये भी आपको देखने को मिल रहा
होगा की यू एनएससी india.com उसके बाद
क्या की ब्लू amazon.com फिर इंडिया तो
इनके बड़े में क्या है इंडिया है जैसे
सर्विसेज डॉट इंडिया डॉट गवर्नमेंट डॉट इन
जैसे ये रहा पहले फुटबॉल
match.com इस पर एचटीटीपी इंडिया डॉट
स्टार्ट डॉट बीजी अब इंडिया में इसको
देखने को मिल रहा है
तो प्लीज
सॉरी पर डिस्टरबेंस तो इस तरीके से क्या
है एक तो ऐसे कर सकते हैं दूसरा मैंने
क्या किया अब ओके चलो मैं ऐसा नहीं कहता
मैंने क्या किया की ठीक है बस वो साइड
साइड डॉट मैं कौन सी चाहता हूं डॉट कॉम
जिसकी डॉट कॉम okay.com ही रखना हूं उसके
बाद इन यूआरएल में क्या है इन यू आर ल
उसके इन यूआरएल में क्या है
सी के है खाना चाहिए उनके बड़े में अब वो
साड़ी साइड आपको देखने वाले जिसके
इन्होंने क्या है देखने को मिलेगा देखना
जैसे मैं पर वेबसाइट पर एग्जांपल मैंने
इसको ओपन किया तो इनके यूआरएल में भी क्या
है हैक वर्जन देखने को मिला है देखो ये
रहा एक शब्द इधर भी देखने को मिलेगा पर
एग्जांपल लिया था मैं ये रहा आपको दिखता
हूं ये रहा इसको भी न्यू टाइप में ओपन
करता हूं तो देखो आपको देखने को मिलेगी
इसके भी इसको इसने क्या हायड कर दिया उसके
बाद तो है देखने को मिले मिलेगा हर एक
वेबसाइट के तो ये है आपका एक
side.com पर एग्जांपल मैंने सर्च किया की
star.edu
और साड़ी वेबसाइट जिसके लास्ट में वीडियो
ये क्या करेगा वो सारे
साइट आपके स्क्रीन पर शो करेगा जिसके
लास्ट में एडु है लेकिन इन यूआरएल में
क्या है इंडिया देखो इंडिया एडु सभी क्या
है वीडियो वाले मिलेगी देखने को तो इस
तरीके से क्या है की ये आपका google.in चल
रहा है अब पर एग्जांपल मुझे क्या करना है
की मुझे मेरा टारगेट है पर एग्जांपल मुझे
एक कम करता हूं अब मैं एक बुक डाउनलोड
करना चाहता हूं पर एग्जांपल मैं का रहा
हूं साइट
साइट है मेरी उसके बाद
star.com
फाइल टाइप
फाइल टाइप उसके बाद क्या है
फाइल का टाइप क्या है पीएफ है पीएफ हैकिंग
हैकिंग
क्योंकि पीएफ है ओके उसका स्पेस डॉग तो आप
क्या करेंगे
मैं थोड़ा समझा देता हूं आपको इसको
कंट्रोल सी करता हूं इसके बाद ये रहा
क्योंकि इससे पहले वाला जो मैं ये रहा
ये रहा एक मिनट मैं कंट्रोल शिफ्ट
कर रहा हूं
अब देखो इसका मतलब क्या है की वो साड़ी
वेबसाइट लिस्ट आउट करो मेरे गूगल
search.com
वाली वेबसाइट पर वेबसाइट का नाम भी दे
सकते हैं अगर आपको पता है तो यार
पर्टिकुलर इस तरीके से भी दे सकते हो जैसे
मैंने दिया तो उसके बाद क्या करना है
पीपीटी है जो भी है उसके बाद मैंने क्या
है हैकिंग फोटो इमेज मतलब क्या है की उसे
बुक का नाम है ये हैकिंग पर डमीज होना
चाहिए उसके अंदर पीएफ के अंदर तो ओके मैं
इसको क्या करता हूं सर्च कर देता हूं ये
अभी देखना
है
इसके सामने
तो देखो यह हैकिंग फूड पीएफ
फाइल आपको डाउनलोड करनी है कोई बुक
डाउनलोड करनी है तो आपके सामने ए गया देखो
ये पुरी पुरी जो हेगी प्रोडक्ट इमेज वाली
जो बुक्स है आपकी अमेजॉन वगैरा पर पेड़ है
तो इधर आपको देखने को मिल गई अगर मैं एक
कम करता हूं बैग जाता हूं मैंने क्या किया
की आपको किसी ने टास्क दिया की मुझे क्या
करना है अभी जल्दी फटाफट नेटवर्किंग के
ऊपर या किसी के साथ मुझे पीपीटी चाहिए ओके
मैं कर सकता हूं पीपीटी तो कैसे side.com
है side.com पे मुझे जाना है उसके बाद
आपको क्या करना है डबल को डबल को देने का
मतलब क्या होता है की आप क्या कर रहे हो
उसे स्ट्रिंग को उसके अंदर सर्च कर रहे हो
स्ट्रिंग को सर्च कर रहे हो किसी भी
वेबसाइट के अंदर डबल लोड का मतलब क्या है
क्वेरी के अंदर आप पर्टिकुलर कीवर्ड को
क्या कर रहे हो सर दे रहे हो क्योंकि
स्ट्रिंग आप सॉरी स्ट्रिंग ही शब्द बोल
सकते हो तो आप क्या किया डबल को के अंदर
कीबोर्ड देते हैं तो वो उसकी शब्द कहां
हनी चाहिए उसके अंदर नेटवर्क की
नेटवर्किंग कीवर्ड होना चाहिए उसके बाद
फाइल टाइप क्यों होना चाहिए फाइल टाइप
फाइल
टाइप होना चाहिए आपका पर एग्जांपल पीटीसी
पीटीसी और हिट इंटर अब देखना
सॉरी पर यार कोई ना कोई दरवाजे पर आता ही
राहत है
तो अभी कीवर्ड है
फाइल टाइप इसको side.com है सॉरी ओके जो
डॉट कॉम नेट क नेट वर्किंग कर दिया
नेटवर्किंग होना चाहिए
नेटवर्किंग उसके बाद इंटर कीजिए अभी देखो
इसमें आपके स्क्रीन पर रिजल्ट शो कर दिया
पर एग्जांपल मुझे क्या फटाफट कोई पीपीटी
बनानी थी तो इधर से भी जा सकता हूं साइबर
सिक्योरिटी कर दिया कोई हमको तो यहां
देखने को पाइपिंग डाउनलोड होगी या किया
होगा कोई भी एक पीपीटी डाउनलोड होगी पर
एग्जांपल ओपन करता हूं देखो अभी वीडियो
आपको देखने को मिलेगी
नेटवर्क वर्किंग
क्या भेज दो मैसेज में
ओके ओके
अगर आपको पर एग्जांपल मैं आपको दिखता हूं
की अगर आपको किसी एफटीपी सर्वर के बड़े
में
आपको ढूंढनी है आपको क्या करना है अगर ओपन
एफबी सर्विस होते हैं हो सकता है की कोई
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन एफटीपी सर्वर को उसे कर रही
है और उसने क्या किया की कभी ओपनली उसे
किया और इंटरनेट पे तो वो क्या है की वहीं
पर क्या है की उसको सीकर करना भूल गई या
उधर इस नो ओपन छोड़ हुआ है और ऐसे ही
बिल्कुल एक सीरियस
कंफीग्रेशन में आई है तो वहां पर क्या हुआ
की वो ओपन एफबी सर्विस नहीं छोड़ दिया तो
उसको अगर फाइंड आउट करना है की ओपन
इंटरनेट पर कितने ओपन पड़े हैं तो उसके
लिए आप क्या करोगे
side.com यहां पर देखने को मिल रहा है
नेटवर्क फाइल जो मैंने यहां पर इसको बोलते
हैं टाइटल तो टाइटल में क्या होना चाहिए
डबल को दिए इंडेक्स ऑफ इंडेक्स ऑफ होना
चाहिए उसके बाद नेक्स्ट
इन यूआरएल इन यूआरएल में क्या होना चाहिए
अब सर्च करने को कितने फटी देखने को मिल
रहे हैं आपको गैस एक चीज ध्यान में रखना
की इनफॉरमेशन कलेक्शन इस नोट डी ऑफेंस
ऑफेंस तब है की अगर आप क्या है की
प्रॉब्लम यहां पर यह आई है की बहुत लोग
क्या-क्या नए होंगे तो क्या करें जैसे
इनफॉरमेशन मिलेगी उसको मिस उसे शुरू करना
शुरू कर देंगे एक्चुअल में तो ये जो
इनफॉरमेशन अभी आपके सामने जो मिलेगी वो
इनफॉरमेशन वो है की जो बहुत पहले से ही
पड़ी है जो अभी एक्टिव नहीं होगी अगर आपको
बाय चेस ऐसा लगता है की कोई एक ऐसी साइट
है जो जिसने सिक्योरिटी मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
है उसने एफटीपी सर्वर को ओपन छोड़ दिए हैं
और कुछ एक सीरियस है आपको ऐसा कुछ लगता है
उसको रिपोर्ट कर दीजिए उसकी ईमेल निकालो
और उसको रिपोर्ट कर दीजिए उसका मिस उसे
नहीं करना है अगर आप मिसयूज करोगे तो आप
सीरियस प्रॉब्लम में पढ़ सकते तो जैसे की
यहां पर देख सकता हूं मैं इंडेक्स ऑफ मेल
melbs.org अब या इसको ओपन करके देखो यहां
बहुत कुछ आपको देखने को मिल रहा है 1.62
ये है वो देखो
मिलते हैं अभी क्या है अभी पहले कंफर्म कर
लेते क्या सच में ये है भी है कुछ है नहीं
तो एक बार मैं क्या करता हूं इसको ओपन
करता हूं ये रहा वेबसाइट को
ट्राई करता हूं खोलना की
कॉपी और पेस्ट किया ये कोई वेबसाइट है या
ऐसे ही
है
माइक्रो
देखने को मिल रहा है अब डाटा
मैं इसको क्या है की एक बार ओपन करके
देखते हैं हम थोड़ा एग्जांपल टेबल ओपन
करके देखते हैं क्या देखने को मिल रहा है
टेबल ये तो इसमें क्या है
देखो टेबल्स की इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल
रही है
है तो अभी इसकी नोट गारंटी की यह क्या है
की अभी तक रिपोर्ट होगी होगी क्योंकि काफी
पुराना डाटा बेस है आप चाहे तो उसके बाद
देख सकते हो बट क्या है की देखो ये काफी
पुरानी ड्रेस है 2005 का है
तो बहुत लोगों ने देखा ही होगा बट क्या की
इस तरीके से किसी भी आपके भी सर्विस की
आपको डिटेल देखने को मिल शक्ति है तो अभी
इससे ज्यादा हम इससे आगे बड़े नहीं बढ़
इससे आगे नहीं बढ़ेंगे हम तो इस तरीके से
आप ये है की सारे ओपनस एफटीपी सर्विस पे
पड़े हुए हैं इंटरनेट पे ये उसकी लिस्ट है
इसमें क्या की इंडिटल इंडेक्स ऑफ ये होना
चाहिए टाइटल में और एफपी अगर आप चाहते हो
सॉरी तो ये दो बहुत ही काफी ओल्ड डाटा ए
रहा है तो मैं क्या कहना चाहता हूं की मैं
उसको फिल्टर करना चाहता हूं ओके आफ्टर
उसके बाद मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं आफ्टर
और मैं चाहता हूं की 2020 के बाद का कोई
डाटा चाहता हूं ऐसा भी कर सकते हो आप
ये क्या है अभी रिजल्ट कितने गया था
गवर्नमेंट वेबसाइट
है तो
यह देखो यह काफी कुछ है जैसे की यह राय
एफटीपी सर्वर टाइम टाइमलाइन है यह देखो
यह इसमें क्या है की ऑब्जरवेशन सेट यह कुछ
है सीआईडी ओके टारगेट साइंस इंस्ट्रूमेंट
कुछ है इसके एफसी
टाइम कुछ लोग टाइप का बना हुआ है कुछ है
तो बट अब ये क्या है सच में ये कोई
वेबसाइट है भी या आज आईटी इस ऐसे
एसीआईडीपीएस है तो मतलब देखो मिल रहा है
उसमें कुछ समय क्या है एफपी से रिलेटेड
देखने को मिल रहा है
देख सकते हो की क्या सच में रिपोर्ट कल
लायक है या नहीं देखो एक वेबसाइट है मतलब
एक वेबसाइट है रियल वेबसाइट है एजुकेशन
वेबसाइट है तो आप चाहे तो इसको क्या कर
सकते हो
आप इसको क्या है हंटिंग करके देख सकते हो
अगर आपको किसी को बाउंड्री मिलता तो ट्री
कर सकते हो ओके तो एक अच्छी वेबसाइट है
अभी इसके गारंटी की ये क्या है जो डाटा है
क्या इसके लिए कॉन्फिडेंशियल है या क्या
है ये साड़ी चीज मेन रखती है अभी इसमें
आपको पढ़ना पड़ेगा इस चीज को सब सर्च करना
होगा तो इस तरीके से देखो और भी बहुत कुछ
है टाइमलाइन है ये मतलब काफी कुछ एक लोग
टाइप का कैट हो रखा है पूरा इसमें और वो
क्या बोल सकते हैं इसमें इंडेक्स ऑफ ओके
इंडेक्स ऑफ और भी बहुत साड़ी चीज देखो पेज
2 हो जाएंगे यानी आपको देखने को मिलेगा
एफटीपी मतलब आपको ऐसे वेबसाइट को कंफर्म
करके भी देख रहा है cest.com जैसे ये रहा
अगर मैं इसको ओपन करके देखा हूं क्या
इसमें है कुछ
तो ये अप से रिलेटेड कनेक्शन मतलब ये क्या
है की कुछ ऐसे ही है अगर इसको सर्च करके
देखो क्या ये कोई वेबसाइट है मुझे लगता
नहीं कोई वेबसाइट होगी
एक बार में कभी भी इतनी आसानी से आपको
इनफॉरमेशन
आपको देखने को मिलेगा ऐसा मत सोचो की ना
आसन है इतना आसन तो सभी क्या है ढूंढ की
रिपोर्ट कर चुके थे
क्योंकि इनको बहुत टाइम देना पड़ता है हर
चीज को इविल डेड करना पड़ेगा
है तो यह आपका एक तरीका की एफटीपी के बड़े
में अगर आपको कोई इनफॉरमेशन मिले कोई
इनफॉरमेशन निकाल सकते हो तो निकाल सकते हो
और जैसे पर एग्जांपल अभी मुझे क्या करना
है की अगर मुझे
एक आपको सुना होगा की आ अगर आपको पता होगा
की जो डॉग्स हैं आपको पता है की एक वर्स्ट
टॉप 10 है जिसमें सिक्योरिटी लॉजिंग और
मॉनिटरी फेलियर का एक
वो है
मतलब क्या है की जो लोग की बात करते हैं
लोग एक बहुत ही ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट चीज
होती है किसी भी कंपनी के लिए किसी भी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के लिए और वो रेगुलरली
मॉडर्न किया जाता है मॉनिटर किया जाता है
कोई भी किसी भी सर्वर में कुछ भी कम होता
है जिसके अंदर लोग इन लोग आउट हो रहा है
उसे पर कोई भी कम होता है तो वो क्या है
लोग कर लिया जाता है और उसकी क्या है एक
फाइल एक डायरेक्टरी एक सर्वर पूरा बैकअप
सर्वर मेंटेन किया जाता है अगर कोई आपको
कोई एक ऐसा यूआरएल मिलता है जिसकी फाइल्स
आपको ओपन मिल जाति है लोग फाइल आपको देखने
को मिल जाति है इंटरनेट पे अगर उसकी आपको
इंटरनेट पर लोग फाइल देखने को मिल रही है
तो वो आप क्या कर सकते हो रिपोर्ट कर सकते
हो तो जैसे की पर एग्जांपल वो कैसे हैं
उसके लिए जो गूगल लोड होता है वो है
नेक्स्ट है मैंने पर एग्जांपल यूजर नाम
फाइल टाइप उसके बाद मैंने क्या दिया
नेक्स्ट उसके बाद प्रोग्राम
अपना कम कर रही है
न्यू पेज में ओपन करता हूं तो अभी देखा
हूं मैं यहां पे कुछ है ओके
सर्चिंग क्या है 42 रिजल्ट आया ओनली एक और
चीज होती है जो आपको गूगल के बड़े में
बताता हूं की टूल्स आपको देखने को मिल रहा
है अब आपको रिजल्ट कोड भी नहीं मैच करना
अगर आपको रिजल्ट क्या है की अगर आपको मुझे
मैंने बोलूं या तो क्या की 42 रिजल्ट अगर
यहां पर 42000 रिजल्ट है मुझे क्या करना
है की मैं देखना चाहता हूं सारे के सारे
देखना चाहता हूं बहुत पुराने जितने पुराने
सारे देखना बताता हूं की मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं
करके दिखा पाएगा नहीं दिखा पाएगा सिंपली
होता है टूल्स में जाइए यहां पे जो रिजल्ट
है मतलब जो रिजल्ट यहां पे अन्य टाइम यहां
पर
चाहिए पेस्ट 20 हॉर्स पर अवर के चाहिए
पेस्ट वीक के चाहिए फास्ट मठ के रिजल्ट
चाहिए या पेस्ट एयर का रिजल्ट चाहिए कस्टम
रिज्यूम सेट कर सकते हो यहां पर कब से
लेकर कब तक के ये क्लक लेंगे किस डेट से
लेकर किस डेट तक की आपको लोग देखना चाहते
हो रिजल्ट देखना चाहते हो वो भी आप ये
गूगल सर्च के इंजन का उसे करके देख सकते
हो ये भी एक एडवांस फीचर है इसका आप इसको
उसे कर सकते हैं तो अब यहां देखो कुछ खास
तो होगा नहीं इसमें क्योंकि एक वेबसाइट है
एमएल का फ्री ओके और टक्स अब इसमें क्या
है की मुझे लगता है की कुछ खास होगी नहीं
है वेबसाइट
कुछ नहीं है कम
करते-करते लोग क्या की बैग फाइंड आउट कर
ले तो उसको और रिपोर्ट कर देते और भगवती
अच्छी खासी उनको मिल जाति है बट क्या है
की अब वो काफी मेहनत करनी पड़ती है काफी
रिसर्च करनी पड़ती है उसके बाद उसको
कंटिन्यू इन्वेंटर करना पड़ता है की क्या
वो सही है या गलत देखो ये रहा अभी कोई ना
कोई लोक संगीत है
किसी सिस्टम के लोग हैं देखो यहां पर कुछ
ना कुछ सिस्टम के ये लोग हैं
security.net एक वेबसाइट है इसके देखिए
कुछ सिस्टम के लोग आपको देखने को मिलेंगे
2017 के लोग सही है अगर मैं इसको ओपन करता
हूं वेबसाइट को
कॉपी और पेस्ट
कॉपी
नेटवर्क एक ये है वेबसाइट
कोई छोटी सी वेबसाइट कुछ बना रखा किसी पेज
बना रखा है अब इसे कुछ लोग बड़े
हुए हैं तो कुछ ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट तो मुझे
लगी नहीं है
रिजल्ट को देख सकते हो पर एग्जांपल ये
देखो ये आपकी कोई कौन सी भाषा में आपको
समझ में नहीं ए रहा ओके ये कोई भी कुछ मिल
गया
ग्रुप सिलेबस यही है आप चाहे तो इसको क्या
कर सकते हो ट्रांसलेट कर सकते हो तो ये था
एक और किंग अगर पर एग्जांपल आपको क्या
करना है ओपन एफबी का मैंने बता दिया
अगर आपको क्या करना है गूगल दो की हेल्प
से आप ईमेल्स को भी फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं
ईमेल्स को कैसे फूल इमेज को हो सकता है
कोई कंपनी में क्या किया की कभी आपकी
एक्सल फाइल में ईमेल को से करके शेर किया
और किसी के साथ अगर और धोखे सेवोक इंटरनेट
पे अभी तक रुकी हुई है इंटरनेट पर राखी
हुई है वो भी एक सेंसेटिव इनफॉरमेशन लीकेज
हो सकता है उसकी एम्पलाई की पुरी ईमेल
लिस्ट है तो उसके लिए भी एक होता है की
फाइल टाइप
मैंने इसके अंदर फाइल लिखा है एक गोल गोल
है ये उसके बाद फाइल में क्या लिखा एक्स
सी
ल एस है फाइल टाइप होता है किसका आपको पता
है
यहां पर अब यहां पे देख सकते हो
पानी है यह आप लोग खुद से ट्राई कर सकते
हैं कुछ अगर सेंसेटिव मिलता है किसी
वेबसाइट से रिलेटेड तो आप क्या कर सकते हो
यू कैन ट्राई तू रिपोर्ट ये आपको सारे पेज
पे जाके सर्च करना है फ्रंट पेज पे ही वो
आपको हो सकता है की जो चीज आपके लिए
सेंसेटिव हो या जी चीज को आप फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश कर रहा हो सकता है की आज तक
वो कोरोला उसको करो करने में क्या की
इंडेक्सिंग है उसकी जो रैंकिंग है काफी
पीछे हो तो इसलिए सारे पेज आपको क्या करना
चाहिए स्क्रॉल करके देखना चाहिए सारे पेज
पे जाके देखना चाहिए और साड़ी वेबसाइट बता
रहे हैं हो सकता है की आपका जो आप पता
करने की कोशिश कर रहे हो वो आपके 200 भैया
इसमें से कोई लास्ट वाला दो रिजल्ट हो
बाकी सारे फेक हो तो ऐसा भी हो सकता है तो
आप के हाथ में आपको कैसे google.com उसे
करना है
तो एक यह तरीका था अगर ईमेल से वगैरा को
कई बार क्या होता है की जब भी कोई भी एक
कंपनी का है वेब सर्वर को क्या करती है
होस्ट करती है पर एग्जांपल अपाचे का भी
होता है कई बार वेब सर्वर किसी भी उसका
होता है तो बाय डिफॉल्ट वहां पर राहत है
हो सकता है की उसमें वो वेब सर्वर डेप्लॉय
कर दिया और जो उसके भाई डिफॉल्ट वाइस चीज
थी क्योंकि जो ओवर हार्डिंग होता है वो
ढंग से नहीं कर पाया होंगे| जो हार्डिंग
पार्ट है वो ढंग से नहीं किया होगा जो बाय
डिफॉल्ट वाली चीज उनको रिमूव नहीं किया
होगा तो अगर वो मुझे फाइंड आउट करना है तो
अभी मैं करता हूं इन टाइटल इन टाइटल उसके
बाद मैंने क्या किया मैं सर्च करता हूं
टाइटल के अंदर
उबंटू और टी यू वन तू उसके बाद
पेज उसके बाद क्या कर सकते हैं सर्च मार
सकते हैं ये देखो ऐसे या हम उसके लास्ट
में पूरा किया जाता है तो हिट बॉक्स आईटी
इंटर
तो इस आईपी एड्रेस अगर देखने को मिलेगा तो
ठीक है नहीं तो किसी दूसरे को चेक कर
लेंगे
कुछ
नहीं
चाहिए ना
यू कैन डू एनीथिंग
तुम्हारे एलिमेंट
को मिल रहा है तो इस तरीके से आपको क्या
है तो
और भी है पर एग्जांपल
छोड़ दिया है ओपन छोड़ दिया है तो कैसे
सर्च कर सकते हैं आपको क्या करोगे सिंपली
उसे करोगे इंडेक्स ऑफ इंडेक्स ऑफ करोगे
उसके बाद सिंपली आप क्या लिखोगे उसके बाद
इन यूआरएल इन यूआरएल उसके बाद गूगल डोर के
ये है आपका पी हा पी
ए दी एम आई पी हा बी मैं एडमिन आईटी इंटर
देखो ऐसा कोई पेज आपको देखने को मिलता है
जो आपका बाय डिफॉल्टर देगा इंडेक्स ऑफ
पीएसपी मी हेड में ये कौन सी वेबसाइट है क
अब यहां
वैलिड वेबसाइट
इसके अंदर आप इंटर भी कर सकते हो क्या
ने यह कोई वैलिड वेबसाइट नहीं है देखो
इन्होंने क्या पुरी वेबसाइट के ओपन करके
रखा हुआ है देखो ये रहा
इस तरीके से आपको क्या है की 100 में से
80 या 90 वेबसाइट पर ऐसी मिलेगी जो फेक
होगी
क्या मतलब 6 पे आता हूं तो यहां भी आपको
देखने को कुछ ना कुछ मिलेगा ये रहा अब मैं
इसको ओपन करता हूं देखो यहां पर है क्या
ये कोई वेबसाइट है ओके इसको सर्च करते हैं
देखो ये कोई एक वेबसाइट है बट क्या इसको
लगता है कोई फ वैल्यू पेज है आपका टोकन
डॉट एचपी है आपको देखने को मिल जाएगा
ट्रांसलेटर डॉट एचपी तो ओपन लिस्ट डॉट
एचपी और आपको देखो देखो देखो बहुत कुछ मिल
रहा है देखो बहुत कुछ है
जैसे
ओके हम इसमें क्या कर सकते पहले डायरेक्टर
बता कर देख सकते हैं ओके दिन के अंदर जाकर
देखो
यहां पर क्या है पी हा पी कोड आपको देखने
को मिल रहे हैं उसके बाद
मतलब पूरे खुला पड़ा है तो कुछ है इसका
मैसेज मतलब
कर दीजिए सबसे बेस्ट ये रहेगा आपके लिए
बाकी और कुछ नहीं तो इस तरीके से क्या है
की आपको मैंने बता दिया की इस तरीके
से
एक तो हो सकता है
सर्च
बिल्कुल
उसे कर सकते हैं
दूसरा क्या हो सकता है आपका
गूगल
डोर के
बाद है
[संगीत]
उन्होंने गूगल हैकिंग डेटाबेस में भी है
एक चिड़चिड़ा आई है इसके लिए किसके लिए
लेटेस्ट वाली है
देखो
पर एग्जांपल
देखो यहां पर कुछ ना कुछ देखो अभी मैंने
क्या किया ऑनलाइन
सर्विस
के तो इस टाइप से क्या की आप इस डाटा पूरा
उसे पेज कंटिन्यू लॉगिन पोर्टल तो क्या है
की इसने इसको सबमिट किया है अगर आप इसका
इनका भी उसे करना चाहे तो आप कर सकते हो
तो यहां पे भी क्या है गूगल डॉग्स की चीज
सीट है आप एक-एक करके उसे करके देख सकते
हो अपनी रिटायरमेंट के हिसाब से
₹76 एंट्री है इसके अंदर इतने गूगल डॉग्स
हैं आपके सामने तो आप चाहे तो कुछ भी इसको
उसे कर सकते हो तो ये था आपका गूगल डोर की
इससे ज्यादा तो और तो क्या चाहिए मैंने ये
आपकी गूगल
कर सकते हो सर्च कर सकते हो
गूगल
डॉग्स चीट सीट और मिल जाएंगे
देखो इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो यह
चीज को रेफर कर के आप अपने कम कर सकते हैं
आप चाहे तो अपने खुद के ही बना सकते हो तो
वह भी आप सिख सकते हो
कमेंट करके बताइए की
सबको समझ में आया नहीं आया
होगा
आपके पास 5 मिनट है कोई डाउट पूछना है तो
पूछ सकते हैं
कैसे उसे करती है
हम इनफॉरमेशन गदर भी करेंगे
डायरेक्ट सर्च
का बेसिकली मतलब क्या होता है की जितने भी
वेब पेज है ना आपके वेबसाइट के अंदर जितनी
वेब पेज है उन वेब पेज के अंदर वो टैक्स
जहां जहां उसको देखने को मिलेगा वो उसको
सर्च करेगा ओके
वेब पेज
होते हैं ना उसके अंदर तो उसके अंदर वो
क्या आएगा आपको सर्च करके दे देगा
और कुछ
और काफी लोग हैं आई एम वेरी हैप्पी
और मुझे लगता है की कल के बाद क्या है 10
आएंगे उसके बाद नेक्स्ट क्लासेस में पांच
आएंगे इस नेट क्लासेस में दो आएंगे
देखो क्या है ना की गूगल डोर किंग एक
एडवांस सर्च इंजन बेसिकली क्या है की जब
आप क्या करोगे
या पेन टेस्टिंग करोगे या किसी भी टारगेट
के बड़े में सर्च कर डॉग तो आपको क्या है
की उसके बड़े में मैक्सिमम इनफॉरमेशन
चाहिए तो मैक्सिमम इनफॉरमेशन एप्लीकेशन
टारगेट कोई वेबसाइट है पेपर क्या होता है
की कुछ ऐसे डेटाबेस होते हैं हमारे इस
गूगल के पास पर एग्जांपल जिसके पास मोबाइल
नंबर है हमारे ईमेल एड्रेस है कौन से जो
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल है अब आपको तो नहीं पता
उसे चीज का ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के पब्लिक के लिए
अवेलेबल और डेटाबेस का तो क्या करोगे गूगल
टॉकिंग का उसे करके उसे इनफॉरमेशन को
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश कर सकते हैं
नॉर्मल अगर सर्च इंजन से उसे करोगे तो आप
के लेवल की इनफॉरमेशन नहीं मिलेगी आप
बेसिकली क्या करोगे की गूगल ड्यूरिंग का
उसे करके वो इनफॉरमेशन फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश कर रहा हूं क्योंकि आपका सबसे पहले
मोटो जो होता है इंटेलिजेंस होता है किसी
भी
इनफॉरमेशन सिक्योरिटी के लिए तो ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस जब करते हो तो आप क्या है
नेक्स्ट ट्राई करते हो की किसी भी टारगेट
के लिए किसी भी परसों के लिए जब जिसको भी
आप क्या कहना चाहते हो और करना चाहते हो
जिसके बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन
आप कलेक्ट कर सकते हो चाहे वो से मिले
किसी टोल से मिले जितनी इनफॉरमेशन आपको
देखने को मिलती है वो साड़ी कर सकते हो
कोशिश कर सकते हो
आप ही बताओ किसी का फोन नंबर कैसे निकाल
सकते हो यार बताओ आप
अगर किसी का फोन नंबर
निकाल कर दिखाना
देखो एक चीज कहना हमारे क्या की इंडिया
में लगा लो कहानी भी की
प्रोफेशनल एथिकल हैक
30% यह 70% है
ना
वह अनगाइडेड होते हैं जिनके पास कुछ नॉलेज
है नहीं बस जो मिला वह उठाकर उसमें कॉपी
पेस्ट कर दिया वो होते है स्क्रिप्ट
इतने डेंजर्स होते हैं ना उन्हें पता नहीं
एक्चुअल में चीज क्या है वो सब क्या कर
रहे थे की उसे वो इनफॉरमेशन मिली और
इनफॉरमेशन उठा के उसका मिस उसे करना शुरू
कर देते हैं और इस चक्कर में क्या कहां
चले जाते हैं अभी जय में
कुछ पता ही नहीं है मालूम नहीं है क्योंकि
प्रोफेशनल हैकर क्या करता है प्रोफेशनल एक
एथिकल हैकर की बात कर रहा हूं प्रोफेशनल
एथिकल हैकर एथिकल हैकर क्या करता है की वो
इनफॉरमेशन कलेक्ट करता है स्टार्टिंग में
हर कोई होता है उसके बाद उसे रिटायरमेंट
के हिसाब से वो जो भी रिटायरमेंट है चाहे
उसको नेटवर्क पार्ट सीखना है उसको कोडिंग
सीखनी है वो साड़ी अपने डोमेन के हिसाब से
वो साड़ी चीज सीखना है और खुद की
डेवलपमेंट करता है और उसके बाद वो
टेस्टिंग करता है वो होता है प्रोफेशनल
एथिकल हैकर और उसे यह भी पता राहत है कौन
सी इनफॉरमेशन कितनी सेंसेटिव हो होती है
कौन सी इनफॉरमेशन किसके पास हनी चाहिए
किसके पास नहीं हनी चाहिए कौन सी
इनफॉरमेशन क्वेश्चन को वो उसे कर सकता है
किस इनफॉरमेशन को उसे नहीं कर सकता कौन सी
इनफॉरमेशन करो मिस उसे करेगा तो क्या उसके
सरकमस्टेंसस हो सकते हैं वो साड़ी चीज
प्रोफेशनल एथिकल हैकर को पता होता है
लेकिन एक स्क्रिप्ट टेढ़ी होता है जो
स्टार्टिंग में अपने आप को यह समझना है की
अगर मैंने फेसबुक हैक किया या इंस्टाग्राम
हैक कर लिया तो मैं बहुत बड़ा पहाड़ टोली
है मैंने कुछ कर लिया तो मैं हैकर का
लॉन्ग इसके अलावा मैं कोई भी एथिकल हैकर
नहीं कहूंगा अगर किसी को ऐसा लगता है की
मैं इटेल हैकर हूं और मुझे क्या की फेसबुक
इंस्टाग्राम हैक नहीं कर पे तो मैं हैकर
नहीं हूं तो यू कैन लाइव दिस क्लास आपको
आने की जरूर नहीं है मैं खुद बोलना हूं यह
चैनल उनके लिए नहीं है जो ओनली स्क्रिप्ट
कीड़ी बने आए हैं
उनके लिए नहीं है
ठीक है स्टार्टिंग
के बाद आपको उसे जी डोमेन में आपको जाना
है अगर एवं आपका नेटवर्क डोमेन है नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी है ये आपका क्लब सिक्योरिटी
डोमेन है एवं आपका क बंटी है उसके हिसाब
से आपको अपने आपको अपग्रेड करना होगा अपने
आप को उसके बड़े में सीखना होगा अगर आपको
उसे उसके अनुसार स्टील को चीजों सीखोगे
नहीं बस स्किप किडनी बैंक रहोगे तो यू आर
डी वेरी डेंजरस परसों तू अन्य वन ये हर
कोई आपको बता देगा क्योंकि आप प्रोफेशनल
नहीं हो और आपको पता नहीं की सही और गलत
क्या है क्योंकि आपने प्रॉब्लम तो यही है
की आपको सही गलत का पता नहीं है बस
ब्लाइंड्ली आप लगे हुए हो की मुझे बस एक
शब्द की धुन में हो मुझे ये करना वो करना
है लेकिन आता कुछ नहीं है
क्योंकि आप लोगों को यही है तो चलो फिर
सेशन
कैसे चेक कर सकते हैं
की हम क्या करेंगे जब हमारे कुछ पार्ट्स
हैं कुछ
यूजरनेम एन्यूमरेशन वाले जो पार्ट रहेंगे
इसमें कुछ और सेंट वाले रहेंगे उसके थ्रू
आप चेक कर सकते हो अगर आपका अवेलेबल है तो
इनफॉरमेशन आपकी अवेलेबल मिलेगी ओके तो एक
कम करते हैं फिर सेशन को और करते हैं और
नेक्स्ट सेशन में मिलते हैं थैंक यू
एक बार से फिर से रिक्वेस्ट है प्लीज लाइक
और सब्सक्राइब करना मत भूलिए और प्लीज
मैक्सिमम लोगो से इसको शेर कीजिए ताकि जिन
लोगों को सच में इनकी जरूर है जिनके पास
पैसे नहीं है जिनको फ्री में एजुकेशन
चाहिए और बेस्ट एजुकेशन चाहिए जिनको फ्री
में सब कुछ सीखना है जिनके पास मतलब
लिमिटेड रिसोर्सेस है प्लीज उनके साथ
कर दिया करो यार खुद से एड हो सब्सक्राइब
कर दिया करो और उसको बताओ की इस टाइम पर
ये चीज आई है आप इसके एटलिस्ट देख सकते हो
ताकि उन लोगों को हेल्प ले वो भी अपनी
लाइफ में कुछ ना कुछ कर पे ओके इस
रिक्वेस्ट पर यू
ओके तो सेशन और करते हैं